كل شيء هنا بات حطاما وكل شيء يذكر بهول
ما حدث وبحجم الماساه ليس الركام فقط بل
وجوه من بقوا وغارت في انفسهم هزات زلزال
وارتداداته في جنديرس المتاخمه للحدود
التركيه شماليه حلب ما تزال عشرات العوائل
تحت ركام بيوتها بانتظار من يكرمهم بدفن
كمن سبقوهم هنا في جنديرس تكشف الصوره
هولا الكارثه التي حلت بالسكان فاحدى اكثر
المدن السوريه المتضرره بالزلزال دفعت
قرابه الف من ارواح ابنائها بينما ماتزال
عوائل باكملها حبيسه هذا الحطام تقول
الفرق المدنيه والميدانيه ان اكتظاظ
المدينه بالمهجرين من المدن الاخرى جراء
الحرب احد ابرز الاسباب في هذا العدد
الكبير للضحايا عدا عن تعداد سكانها
وقربها نسبيا من مركز الزلزال اسبوع مر
على الكارثه ومحاولات الانقاذ توقفت
لتتركز العمليات على اغاثه منحالفهم الحظ
وبقوا على قيد الحياه
لتبقى الحصيله النهائيه للارواح حبيسه
الركام حتى اشعار اخر